[Music]
let's talk about Governor Romney all
right
he's the I have to admit I still don't
feel I know enough about him as a person
I'm very intrigued he doesn't smoke he
doesn't drink he doesn't use caffeine
does this guy have any vices there one
vice that any one of the media has found
well you see his picture from the other
day you know his staff was playing flag
football or something on the beach yeah
the guy's standing there he's wearing
black shorts and like an Under Armor
shirt yeah and he looked like he was 25
years old he's in very good shape that's
what happens I guess when you don't
drink and smoke and he said once on some
radio show I remember playing the same
bikes I couldn't believe it he has a
vice which is when he's feeling really
stressed out at night he has a bowl of
cocoa puffs
he has cocoa puffs that makes me I like
I can relate to that
why is he talking about that that's
relatable that makes him seem a little
more human yeah yeah he doesn't he
doesn't need to have a glass of wine or
you know it's great wine with cocoa
puffs fantastic Count Chocula with
that's fantastic that's even better I
don't want to get into my sugar cereal
fetish or my problem with alcohol late
at night but I do want some of this you
have an idea to amend the way we vote
you want to have a constitutional change
in the way we vote what is it if so I
think you know people sometimes they say
the Constitution every word in it is you
know sacred right yes like some people
see the Bible but some things in the
Constitution could change like that we
have to vote on Tuesday and why not have
I mean that wasn't a very very different
time was back when people were riding
donkeys right they used to get to vote
yes powdered wigs muskets hair kind of
maybe like no this is not anything like
a pen are you talking about no one would
choose this hair
George Washington say get me a carrot
colored confection to put on my head
they had classy white powdered wigs but
now we're way off track yeah um what
would how do we change the way we vote
so I'm thinking what if we voted on the
weekend and you had two full days to
vote everybody can vote no you know some
people their jobs would still make it
difficult for them but then you could
have it just on two days you know to
pull up 48 hours everybody could vote
then a winner is announced does that
work I mean so you'd say a whole two
days to vote so that someone can't say I
couldn't get I couldn't make it there
tonight
I mean cuz some people work on the
weekend so it's hard so this isn't a
hundred percent perfect but a lot more
people are working on a Tuesday it's a
lot harder to vote on a Tuesday than it
is in a Saturday or Sunday okay so you'd
have to amend the Constitution to do
that I can do that don't worry about
that okay so you're saying you're saying
you vote on the weekend okay what about
we have all this amazing online
technology oh yeah we vote on it I
support that to vote online cuz you now
you can put your pie-dar on your new
little iPad Mini or whatever it is you
probably touch it don't have the mini
you don't point at me you know those are
for sissies
I've got the big iPad my manly
lumberjack maxi iPad yeah mine is made
of wood and iron
but anyway so you believe that people
it's true and you believe that people
will be able to just do all this online
at someday and then you'll have a whole
weekend to do it people are just gonna
watch porn you know that don't you
probably that's how we're gonna vote all
right well this is very exciting you
can't make any predictions obviously you
don't know it'sit's that it is
neck-and-neck at this point it is
neck-and-neck I mean that the polls the
polls show it so you're so happy with
your polls more polls coming out every
day there's a new poll guess that's one
point within the larger 17 came out
today and they all agreeing or is there
a consensus among these polls or no it's
a there's a consensus that it's been
getting it's been getting tighter yes
you know before the first debate it was
I would say most people would have said
look this race is gonna go Obama it's
gotten much tighter since then so it's a
margin of error race yes well I think
the good news is no more debates
[Applause]